hey everybody welcome to led live where
we're gonna expose some darkness with
the light of christ
have you ever wondered are all
translations of the bible equal
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness thanks guys for
coming back to another
led show we just love you guys for
subscribing to our channel if you're new
here you're in for a treat
we like to take modern topics and really
just
put the filter of the bible on them and
today we get a lot of questions about
translations of bibles
and there is a new translation called
the passion translation
that we're going to be discussing today
and in fact we're going to do a little
series on
translation so you'll see a couple of
these shows
really trying to tackle this topic how
do we know which
bible we should really be paying
attention to and which ones we should
kind of steer away from so
i'm really excited our guest today
michael banana we've had him on our show
before
and uh michael it's a pleasure to have
you on our show man
second time's a charm and uh thank you
very much for having me again
how are you michael i'm good
how are y'all doing good so tell us a
little bit of
of you know we're getting into this
topic but give us a little background of
of why you know you're interested in
this topic
and uh tell us a little bit about what
what you're up to because i know you're
you're actually studying theology so
give us a little bit of that background
so when all this stuff started you know
the whole coronavirus covet 19
everybody kind of got cooped up in their
house nobody really had
anything else better to do i just
finished helping my dad recover from his
first knee surgery
so i was uh kind of stuck here in new
york and uh
to embedded my time i decided you know
i'm going to dive full head first
into the scripture not that i hadn't
done it before
but i felt like it was really time
because
eggs and now riots are going on and so
i started to look into this stuff i got
non-stop amount of translations i'm
looking at my
wall right here i got one two three four
five six i'm not going to count them all
different translations and somebody
asked me
about the passion translation and what i
thought about it
and uh that sparked this
nice show so you're you're
you're in theology and uh you're kind of
taking a look at
actually a lot of different religions
and um
sort of understanding where a lot of
different perspectives are coming from
at this point aren't you
yeah i've got uh mormonism islam
uh different sects of christianity that
people think
are different religions
and even dabbled a bit in a
hinduism because one of my friends was
interested so
yeah so what what's a lot of different
things what's the purpose of actually
looking into a lot of these different
religious perspectives
so uh my intention and my purpose for
doing this
is to help myself better understand
others to be a better witness to them
i told one of my friends once that uh
you can never be too prepared
because when you are to when you think
you're too prepared
uh you can slip up and not be able to
catch yourself
uh so you have to constantly be ready
and willing i have
first peter 3 15. always be ready and
willing to give a defense for what
the reason you have for this hope amen
and so
there that's the reason
before we get into this topic though i
do want to thank our patreon donors you
guys are
awesome and uh we have had such love and
support coming from you
guys it's been awesome we've been able
to hire new people
we've we've just taken on a whole
spanish channel
and we're going to be turning all of our
english content into
spanish so if you know anybody who
speaks spanish which is pretty much most
of the world
look out for that because we're very
excited to
be able to offer that from little light
studios espanol
we also have t-shirts it's our way of
actually helping
keep the lights on in our ministry so if
you haven't checked them out
look at this some of the t-shirts from
teespring that we have below here
we just absolutely believe everything we
do
can be a witness and wearing a t-shirt
can easily start a conversation
so that's why we have a lot of t-shirts
that have a lot of christian themes in
them
you never know what kind of a
conversation you may have down the road
so check those out they really help our
ministry out
and of course we sell dvds documentaries
and things that
really also help push our content out
into the world so
check those out we've got them on vimeo
for download
and you can check them out at
littlelightstudios.tv
so give us a little background on this
passion um
translation it's a new translation right
so for for our viewers who
probably don't know that this even
exists uh when did this first kind of
hit the scene
and and you know give us the little
backstory of the passion translation
so it came out about a couple years ago
it's a relatively new translation and
it's
rampantly gaining traction within the
uh charismatic movement of the church
um places like bethel uh
and and these type of groups uh it was
uh created by
brian simmons hi i'm brian simmons i'm
the lead translator for the passion
translation
the passion translation is an attempt
to bring god's fiery heart of love
and truth to this generation using
aramaic greek and hebrew manuscripts
merging all of those together
with the emotion and the truth of god's
word
and accuracy coming forth i think you'll
enjoy reading the passion translation
about every hundred years the vocabulary
of people undergoes
a dramatic change and in this era with
modern technology we find an even more
rapid change taking place
in past translations of the bible
scholars
wonderfully gifted scholars were trained
to focus on other factors
beside the emotion of the text as i
study the original
manuscripts of greek hebrew and aramaic
i have uncovered what i believe
is the love language of god and it's
been missing from many modern
translations
god refuses to meet us in an
intellectual way
god wants to meet us heart level so we
must let the words go heart deep
and that's what we're trying to do with
this project is to bring words that
go right through the human soul and past
the defenses
of our mind and goes right into our
spirit
that's where it comes from is this one
man it's a one-man
translation and
yeah and that's a very dangerous thing
if you look at every other translation
we have
uh most of them are committee based uh
which helps make sure that people's
specific doctrines don't uh
overlap or overlay onto what the
scripture actually is trying to say
right that's the danger with one man's
translation
and he you can tell in this book that
even though he says there are some
collaborators
it is very much the
movement that he's part of uh they call
it
signs in one's movement some people call
the new apostolic
reformation uh but that is what
this translation is
do you know if he used the original text
like greek hebrew
aramaic or did he use one of did he
translate from another translation
okay so that that's a that's a story in
and of itself
see um we say translated from the
original hebrew greek in aramaic
but there are no actual aramaic texts
that we have we don't have any
really we only have hebrew and greek
yeah uh and that's
the chapter that nebuchadnezzar wrote
they don't have the original
copy is that the one on the cyber scroll
um the aramaic is nebuchadnezzar's
chapter in the bible
okay because he wrote it in his own
language so they don't have an original
of
that nobody has an original aramaic
of what jesus uh was saying
specifically everything else that has
been translated into the bible
uh was from hebrew and greek that's
really the majority and there's not
much arabic because it is very different
aramaic than we
currently have uh so that's that's a
danger about it um he says
on the website and in this book
like if i go into galatians he says
this pit this is means this
in the original aramaic but we don't
have an air mayor
and he claims uh depending on
who he's talking to
he will say that oh he has um
history translating and he uses the
original greek and hebrew and aramaic
specifically like that or
somebody uh depending on your circle
again he'll say that
he got it from inspiration and feeling
because an angel named passion mercy
yeah interesting yeah galatians 1 8
if even i or an angel comes to you and
speaks any other gospel
well hey joseph smith got his stuff from
an angel right i mean
we don't agree with that i think we can
close this discussion right here yeah
so he actually admits that that he got
it from an angel this is out of his
his mouth those are out of his mouth
and it gets way worse what's scary
is that there's a large group of people
who are believing
this right they believe an angel told
him the truth
a lot of people who are reading this
didn't read the bible that's
in the verses they clearly state it see
and that's the thing
when you look at the history of the
bible and why we even have the
bible today it started off because
people didn't have access to it
that's right isn't that interesting
martin luther steps in he's like no
people should have access to the word of
god
not just listening to the preacher and
and or the priest or whoever
and just taking in what they're saying
now fast forward hundreds of years later
where are we at we have easy access to
it but we're still depending on someone
else instead of
delving into the word of god it's like
they tried to take the light
out of the world right they tried to
just stop people from be able to
to read it now it's like the devil's
like oh well if i can't take it away
from you all i'm going to do is flood it
and i'm going to flood it with like a
variety of things and
and and you know just see if i can
confuse the situation
where so people don't even want to delve
into that
about the the flooding it uh i don't
know if that's what you meant but
uh you shouldn't add to the scripture
right that that's something that is
said um if you go into the psalms
uh psalms 18 specifically uh
i don't know what translation you have
what translation
are you i got angry yeah king james
version mine's called an easy reader so
what they did was just sort of just took
out the
vowels and the but left the the verse
basically intact
okay so i have the csb in front of me so
that's where i
uh based what i'm talking about on this
specifically
uh there are 809 words in psalms 18
in the csb translation
there are 1286 words
in the passion translation oh wow which
is more than any other
translation niv only has 859 words
right that's 400 extra words
wow yeah that's over 400 extra words
it's kind of funny because usually
we get on we get on transitions because
they remove stuff and here we have a
situation where he's adding yeah that is
interesting
he says that he i puts in italics what
he adds but he breaks that rule all the
time
like there is only like one section in
psalm 18
that has italics everything else is
regular right wow right interesting i'm
going to throw a question at you
why do you use the king james version um
i personally like the language of it um
i i i just kind of like gravitated
towards when i came back into the church
to king james and i just
that's what i kind of fell in love with
reading and and i like it
um but this particular bible actually
underlines various different words in
here that that maybe perhaps you would
want to see
from different translations and then
gives you a definition of what they
meant by that word so
this bible kind of incorporates the idea
of of having
multiple translations to sort of see
what that what that real meaning was
um it was like a study bible of sorts
yeah so so i've kind of really
appreciated it plus um
it has like a like a red letter in the
old testament which
which i think is nice you can kind of
see when god is talking
as opposed to just man and so there's a
few things about this bible i appreciate
i use the king james as well um when i
first
started getting in i'm actually going to
read the bible i would have already been
a christian for a while but was just
going to church and getting it that way
and then i had a desire to read the
bible somebody gave me a new living
translation and said it's a little bit
easier to read
i didn't know i think it's actually like
a paraphrase but um
it is viewed as a paraphrase yes okay so
i was reading it
and um i started studying with this guy
and there was actually
three really like to me they were just
like supernatural
things that were like go back to the
king james version
um and then i was given this book called
in all of thy word i actually sent you
a pdf for that i don't know if you've
ever heard of that book michael but
it's a book the size of a dictionary all
about why the king james is like
the best version really um but one one
thing that stood out specifically
was i was studying with a guy about the
sabbath and he told me to read
um isaiah 66 23.
so i turned to isaiah 66 23 in my new
living translation and i read
all humanity will come to worship me
from week to week and from month to
month
so and he said really that's what yours
says he said read mine
do you have it scotty yeah and it shall
come to pass that from
one new moon to another and from one
sabbath to another
shall all flesh come to worship me says
the lord
isn't that interesting that in the last
days there's going to be people who are
remnant who keep the commandments of god
and this translation has
changed one word that seems kind of
insignificant the word sabbath to the
word weak
but that was enough for me to say you
know what no
i'm never reading this stuff again i'm
going to and i'm not so adamant like
king james only i will
if i see a really good verse i i will
compare it with other
translations and see if there's a
version that makes it a little more
understandable but doesn't change the
context
and i'll share that verse that way but i
won't
i won't read like the whole version of
the bible that way and it shall be
from new moon to new moon from the
sabbath to sabbath
all mankind will come to bow down before
me says the lord well that's awesome it
actually doubled up
sabbath the sabbath instead of one
sabbath to another so if that's the
closest translation that's pretty cool
this is what is considered the new
american standard bible is considered
the closest to the original
hebrew and greek that we have in english
well i might have to consider that
everybody in this room has kjv i guess
i'll pull out my kjv
nice thou need us to read a thing
why i particularly use the king james is
because i know that it was translated
first from
the original text and i know that a
committee put it together
and that was the original translation
into the english text
and then as time goes on you have all
these different translations and it
seems kind of like watered down and
matching
specific people's ideologies and if you
look at who favors certain bibles this
bible passion bible is liked by bethel
church and all these other churches like
it's
you can see churches right you can see
why there's bias you can see why they're
shifting more towards a particular bible
and that raises a red flag for me
right whereas king james is kind of
across the board right we see that same
sort of thing with the lgbt
plus um community as well they're
actually
starting to remove certain things from
the bible that would go along with their
thinking
which then you know begs the question um
well where's this line of truth there
has to be a line of truth
uh otherwise if it's just left up to
whatever sub group
wants the bible to say whatever they
want to say then all of a sudden
you're going to go along with that so um
i know i
i appreciate the amount of energy and
effort that actually went in for some of
these
um translations like the king james and
and yeah
i i see the same thing now i've heard
you have to fact check me on this but
i've heard in california it's illegal
now
to speak against homosexuality from the
pulpit
so now we're being censored even if it's
in the word of god you're not allowed to
preach it
that's just like what they're doing in
china they have a government-approved
bible
so if you have a church you're going to
have the government-approved version of
the church
and everything's recorded cameras
everywhere which they're trying to do in
america too they want your trans
they want uh what are they called the
transcript yeah your transcript from all
your sermons and stuff so
pretty creepy stuff wow
so the passion obviously is is
interjecting their own ideas
yeah uh for instance in uh
first in james 1 26
and 27 right i have it in king james
for y'all if any man among you needs to
be religious
and uh bridleth not his tongue
but deceiveth his own heart this man
religion is vain
your religion is undefiled before god
that's as far as i'm going to go
okay in this translation
in the passion translation it says
religion in 26
where it says uh to seem religious
this man's religion isn't is vain in 27
it says pure spirituality
it changes that word even though in the
greek it's the same exact word
so instead of religion they're saying
spirituality the person's like i'm not
religious
i'm spiritual wow i kind of get it you
know
in this culture we're in you say the
word religion it's got this bad aura or
whatever so they're trying to make it a
little bit
more palatable but but a buddhist can be
spiritual
can be extremely spiritual so that that
leaves that really open-ended
new age of very spiritual pure
spirituality
god doesn't people what you do now you
know people like to go about it now like
relationship over religion it's not a
religion it's a relationship with christ
and while i'm 100 positive we all agree
that it's relationship with christ
that's right it's it's it's a religion
right we
are our definition of religion is wrong
this is the true religion right here
right you can see it in that text when
you say i'm spiritual or not religious
that takes
lifestyle out of your beliefs right you
know when they're listing out what is
religion it's a lifestyle it's what
you're actively doing
in your day-to-day and to say that i'm
spiritual and not use that word
religious and
use the biblical definition of it you
can just go around saying oh yeah i
believe this but i can stay at home i
don't have to
be christ like i don't have to talk to
people i don't have to be a friendly
person or do the right thing
and that i have such an issue issue with
that
um one more thing i want to point out
about it is if you look at any other
translation it says religion twice
even the message translation which
completely omits
all hate all sin about homosexuality
it still says religion in here twice so
the fact that this
does not raises way more red flags than
anything
because you're changing a whole ideology
by stating that
wow wow out of curiosity i was wondering
what that
isaiah 66 22 did say in in that version
here's the fun thing about it you ready
for it yeah yeah
he's pushing this as a man
a what's it called primary translation
right
that's what he's doing um
it's only a new testament with songs of
songs
and psalms yeah i wanted to actually
bring that up it's only the new
testament is there a reason
for that or they just think that the old
testament doesn't apply
or what would be the reason for that
so his reasoning is every single
translation comes out with just the new
testament first
every single one the message translation
was originally just a new testament and
then it became
oh so he's just not finished yet uh yeah
so he's gonna rewrite
exodus
[Music]
normally what happens is you would get
this
you know you would get a new testament
and then that'd be fine and then they
would come out with the full bible after
they're done
but brian simmons is doing something
completely different
he has this and then
let's go on google and type in the
passion translation
old testament or whatever he's coming
out with
the books specifically and at some point
he'll eventually do it but they're
coming out individually
i don't know why but i assume it's for
the love of money so just to clarify the
reason why
just to clarify there will be a passion
genesis passion exodus like
all throughout wow there's a passion
genesis out right now
i saw it in the bookstore the other day
when i went how much is it selling for
the bookstore out of curiosity 94 29 on
amazon prime is the
passion translation 12 in one collection
what's
paperback so this is an easily
accessible book
no not even a little bit you can get it
digitally obviously you can find it
if you type in the passion translation
isaiah 6624 you might be able to find
that
who knows if he's gotten through isaiah
yet if he has it'll be on google
so then i wouldn't question the
intention you create this thing for
everyone to read and everyone can
and understand but you know everyone
can't access still because
if you don't have the money for it
or is it like a dust collector bible you
know people get those fancy
bibles that are like let like the the
leather with the picture on the top and
it's just
a voice right from my caller the family
bible right
family bible yeah uh there are rumors
that in bethel it's the only bible you
can buy at their
church's store i don't know for certain
i've never been to redding california to
know this for fact
but uh that's that's what
is rumored is that this is the only
bible you can get
and if this is the only bible you can
get you're completely voting
the old testament you you except for
psalms and
the song of songs which why the song of
songs
why the song why if you're going to do
this um
the most um interesting book to start
with
but but yeah i i mean i i you may be
hitting the nail on the head right there
is you know there's a lot of feeling
based that
uh religion that comes out of some of
these charismatic movements and
and that's what kind of scares me about
some of the
the songs and things that they're
putting out
is is is the theology is really based on
like i feel god i'm feeling
that he's here and so this would be a
bible that would be
yeah that would be very in line with
that type of thinking whereas like
you know you look at some of the hard
things that that you watch god do in the
old testament and it's like wow this
seems like a totally different god than
this just like feel-good god of
of of the new testament even though it's
the same same god you know it's the same
person
um on mount sinai as it was you know
that was walking around
in amongst humanity so you know both of
these things
play off of each other the old testament
points to the new testament the new
testament points back at the old
testament
and you kind of need both these
witnesses to be able to kind of get a
full picture of god
when you remove aspects of that i think
you open yourself up for danger
and we do get a lot of questions about
you know
the the music that's being put out a lot
of people want us to do an episode on
that
but you can see the the main difference
here or
and it kind of goes throughout
everything i remember talking to my mom
on the calendar if you're curious who
that is check out is justice enough
in that episode but um she was saying
yeah it's the same
you can compare the different
translations and also compare the
different kinds of music
and the ideologies they're pushing
because if you look at bethlehem music
and what's other one hillsong music
those kind of contemporary music
compared to hymns right so with theirs
it's like
they focus on suffering and then because
i feel god i can overcome
whereas the hymns is more of this is
what god can do in my life and that is
why i overcome
so yeah i see that throughout when you
when you're comparing
it's almost like the music is sort of
the setting the stage
for the the theology that's going to
come out of that um
if you would man i can just see like the
new world religion man
i it's all going to be feeling based and
it's all going to be unity
and love and it's all you know
i just want to mention this one thing
about sort of what we're starting to see
here
emerge um you know when the devil used
the snake in the garden of eden we call
that spiritualism
and uh what he was essentially doing was
basically taking the words of god god
said you eat this fruit
you're gonna die and the snake flipped
that around and said no if you eat the
fruit you're not going to die you're
going to live forever right so he's
changing the very words of god and we
know that in the end of the world
we are actually going to deal with
spiritualism like it's preparing
the devil has been working on humanity
for 6 000
years and he's perfected this idea of
spiritualism
simply to change the words of god this
is our road
map literally to understand the
confusing times
that we're going to go through and we're
going to live in or we are living in
right now
like this is what is a lamp into our
feet and a light into our path right
and so if the devil just changes those
words of god
it can throw us off kilter really easy
and so
we need a line of truth that we can
literally stand on
and that is the word of god so he's
going to do all he can to basically
tinker with that
rewrite that so that he can just change
it by the influx of a
you know comma meaning whatever take
this little word out
yeah it's not really religion it's just
spirituality
and then all of a sudden it's like
you've you've gotten lost
right there and what's crazy is he said
that the angel is telling him
this is your position to to write this
new translation like that's what it
sounds like everyone will be using this
translation in the new world religion
so i what would you say to someone who
says wow how can you say
that when the bible writers were
inspired by god
um how they get around it was that the
question
what would you say about it what would
you say to that because this this person
who wrote the passion
he's saying that he was inspired or
visited by an angel
so what if someone says yeah but there's
a verse in the bible that says the bible
writers were inspired by god
i think that's second timothy 3 16.
i think though that those those those
bible writers were writing a book of the
bible not necessarily the whole bible
right
they weren't rewriting the words that
moses wrote and that was the original
yeah they're not making well let me
change it it wasn't good enough the
first time you know
good you want to say something and then
you also take you take a look at the
verse that i mentioned
prior you know if even i or an angel
comes to you and speaks another gospel
right so why do we take
this as the gospel if that's where it
came from
and you take that as well with uh
acts 242 the reason why i say x4
242 is because it's talking about how
these people listen
to their apostles okay
their movement the uh signs and wonders
movements
or the nar new apostolic reformation
appointed uh bill johnson of battle
and brian simmons as apostles so
whenever they say
something they point to acts 242 as an
option as a way of saying that we have
the authority
wow over what is being said inside
scripture
that's how they say it even though the
scripture itself says something
different it says already revealed not
revealing now
mercy wow yeah i often witness
to catholics and i'm like well
if i show them in scripture they're
going to get it and when i show them
they're like no
god gave authority to the church to make
these changes i'm like wow really like
i can't even prove anything from
scripture because if the church says it
it overrides the gospel and it's just
mind-blowing and you've got to think god
is not the author of confusion and that
is confusion in and of itself for him to
speak and then say oh but you can talk
over me it's fine you can change this
if they if you don't have the apocrypha
the neutral canonical books in your
bible they don't view you as real
say what now what did you just say
if you don't have the apocrypha or what
they consider the deuterocanonical books
of the bible in your bible you're not a
real christian to them
wow wow so anything else you're kind of
noticing here in the passion that uh
you know really kind of puts another red
flag
we barely scratch the surface of my
notes so it's really all the questions
you got
like when i said he was visited by an
angel that wasn't all
that's not all he claimed he claimed he
went to the inner library of heaven
got two books from god and then saw john
uh
john 22 oh wow
dude yeah yeah look in your bible
how many chapters of john are there 21
there's actually a 22nd john
according to the uh library of heaven
and jesus told him he couldn't take it
because it was for a later revelation
okay so i just google search john 22 and
what comes up is the new gospel.org
um this is reminding me a lot of
mormonism you know they got the
the new new testament or whatever it's
called the new testament of jesus christ
you know that's that's just dangerous
like
i i think that's why i think that's why
we really need to talk about this kind
of stuff yeah
because if this stuff is flying around i
mean i mean
you know we talk about spiritualism in
the in the movies
i mean all of that is basically just
kind of like
planting seeds in your mind to sort of
be accepting of that but then all of a
sudden you slide underneath the table
that there's all these new
you know biblical words and this extra
added stuff and it's like
lord have mercy how are you ever going
to find the line of truth
if if if you're opening yourself up to
this kind of stuff
i think it goes back to what you said
about the work of the holy spirit
you know that's one thing that can
definitely bring peace peace of mind
and you know taking the instead of us
trying to trust humanity say lord like
this is the best i have this is
the translation that i'm working with
please reveal your word to me
you know i've just heard so many
testimonies of so many people that just
say
lord um just reveal yourself show me
show me where
you know i need to look or where i need
to to be careful of and guide my steps
and stuff and you
if you open yourself up to the holy
spirit like that you will hear that
little
voice in there like there's something
wrong with this or who knows somebody
may stumble across this video right here
and they were asking for
for god to give them confirmation of
truth i think that's that's the
you know the beauty of something like
this is is um
yeah and i was talking to a friend and
they said although the bible is god's
direct line to us he does talk to us in
different ways that's right you know
he can show himself in nature a still
small voice talking directly to you
through a testimony of someone else
so there are different avenues it's not
just the bible
that's right but the bible should be
held
over all right very true this is true i
just say writing the
people in the old time the reformer or
the common people they didn't have
bibles so easily accessible
yet they can know that truth amen yeah
so
i i want to know if there's any more
weird stuff like that
yeah yeah how many more things do you
have like this
ryan simmons has said
jesus is 200
man and then he said
everything that can be said about jesus
can be said about you
because you are wow
this is straight new age that you can
reach a level of god consciousness that
that's what we're doing this is what
this whole experience is about is trying
to obtain
godhood and if the mormons believe it
and now this
new uh new translation of the bible is
teaching that
and the new age movement teaches it then
there's going to be a lot of
a lot of christian groups that are going
to accept this false
doctrine brian's exact words by the way
we are blended into the three and one
everything said about jesus can be said
about you
blended into the three in one you know
if you
if you really don't study the bible you
really
you that may sound great right on the
surface you know what i mean
uh you know the purpose of
the purpose of the christian walk really
or the hope of a christian
is christ in us the hope of glory right
i mean that is
that is what we're we're trying to do is
is jesus is knocking on the door of our
hearts
and we we are to open up the door and
allow jesus
inside of our hearts and look at how
close this is it's like yeah
you have god inside of you but the
influx there is
you are god as opposed to
we're allowing him inside of our hearts
and if god if the three-in-one god is
just as equal to
a sinner like me then what what was the
purpose of dying on the cross
and all of that you know yeah the cookie
kind of crumbles forever
it was just the purpose of it there
always needs to be something to happen
to give
us eternal life to allow us through
maybe yahweh was just the nicest god
and he gave that spiritual son for this
reason or maybe
it's always the case where the spiritual
creation of the previous god
is doing that wow wow
so right off the bat he gets this whole
idea from an angel
he's adding books in there changing
words adding lots of words
can it get any worse than this uh how
about this i'm going to just do
a lightning round okay lightning
we can we can get through it all right
okay so john 1
1 what is it in the beginning god
created the word and the word was or
god sorry
i'm on this created thing here and the
word was god
in the beginning was the word the word
was god
was with god in the beginning was the
word and the word was with god and the
word was god there you go
okay well in the in the very beginning
the living
expression was already there and the
living expression
was with god yet fully god that's what
this says
uh on top of that we go to second
corinthians 5 18 and 19 where in our
bibles it says that our sins are not
counted against us we're in this bible
it says they aren't even recorded
and then uh but just real quick i'm
going to point
to uh one of the things in songs of
solomon uh
or song of songs in uh chapter 2 verse
it's talking about run away with me kind
of feeling that that's what it is
because you know it's all
lovey-dovey uh but in this one
it's actually not the same
213 starts with a question
instead of a love line which the rest of
it is
can you not discern this new day of
destiny
breaking forth all around you the early
signs of my purpose and plans are
bursting forth
the budding vines of new life are now
blooming everywhere the fragrance of the
flowers whispers
there is change in the air arrive my
love my beautiful companion and run away
with me
to higher place for now is the time to
arrive and come away with me
so did you say that was 213. yeah that
was two thirteen
added a whole bunch of stuff that wasn't
even close to what my bible says
that's what i'm saying one other reason
why he wrote this book
greek is a head language where hebrew
and aramaic are for the heart
so god is limited and that is the reason
for this translation
even though greek has 5 million words
and english only has 170 100
for no so 171 476
words and if you go on the website it
says the intention of this
is to get past the defenses of your mind
and get to your heart
mercy come let us reason together that's
a mind thing and did he just say that
god is limited
limited in language like limited in
language in the hebrew
words and there's 5 million hebrew words
and only a hundred and something
thousand
greek there are five million greek words
greek is a head language that's the
problem okay greek is a head language so
he was limited
in the greek yeah so we need to get five
million words
yeah yeah and we have 100
thousand words you know i think taking a
look at this really shows you
where the the line of truth needs to be
it needs to be a head understanding
of of of of this truth you know what i
mean like we cannot trust our hearts we
cannot trust them they're
desperately wicked who can know that the
the feelings based on
on you know like oh i i feel like this
is the truth or right
i want this i mean we we need to know
this is
thus saith the lord and order our lives
after that
and there is a balance because the whole
bible is talking about addressing the
heart
so it goes both ways but in order to
address the heart yes you have to use
your mind you have to make the decision
and that's why i think like you look at
hebrews 11 you look at the faith chapter
right all of these
big men of the faith and and and women
they're
they're ordering their lives after after
what they
understood in their minds with god not
what they were
waiting for i mean i'm sure noah i just
can't wait to actually meet noah someday
right
this guy went 100 and something years of
people thinking he's
nuts and he was just like i'm staying
the course i'm staying the line
and he stayed the line and then god
after all that
puts him in the ark and makes him wait
seven days
before i mean think about what was going
through his mind at that time
did i not hear it right am i crazy like
what what's going on
at this point your wife's probably yeah
you know what i mean your wife's like
let me out of this thing dude who are
you
but here he was literally saying no i
understand what god is
there's people screaming and yelling at
me trying to set the ark on fire no
doubt outside or whatnot
and and he ordered his life after what
he understood god to be in his head
there are so many things in this book
that are just
not not okay like i'm looking at uh
galatians 2 20 right now uh you know the
old identity has
been crucified with christ is no longer
right like you're no longer
you uh because christ lives within you
uh here's some it is in italics but
it is very odd uh my old identity has
been
crucified with the messiah and no longer
lives
for the nails of the cross crucified me
with him and now the essence of the new
life is no longer mine for the anointed
one lives
his life through me we live in union
as one my new life is empowered
by the faith of the son of god who loves
me so much that he gave himself for me
and dispenses his life into mine
that sounds good there was a lot of
concepts there
that were kind of like brought into that
yeah right yeah a
mush where that goes back to the
original
argument to rewrite this because um i
feel like the other
language is a lot easier for me to wrap
my head around you know what i mean
this this sort of just added too much
confusion to the understanding of that
verse
and people thought like scholars looked
at it and thought oh this has got to be
a paraphrase right it would make sense
of the paraphrase
no he's telling you this should be your
primary bible
wow this is this is what he's telling
you is that this is your primary bible
not even eugene peterson said this
should be your primary bible
so what would you say um how
how could you advise or what kind of
um advice would you give to somebody
that's
that's like hey i've been i've been
reading this bible and and
you know what do you think about this
how would you approach this topic with
somebody
well at first i would i would ask them
to
i would point out some of the vertices
that i mentioned i'd be like we'll read
this in any
other translation right and then
afterwards if it's like a pastor or
somebody who's like
well this just this breathes the new
life into it
uh but then i would also tell the tea
the the pastor or the teacher whatever
to look at james three
because not not just in this translation
in any translation
because it's the chapter
that tells you that you're judge harsher
if you're a teacher
yeah yeah are you really going to risk
all the falsities in this book and teach
people
from this book if you're going to be
judged harsher
when it comes time for his return good
point good point
yeah you know i mean i imagine there's
going to be um
a lot of people that's that this is
where i kind of picture
people going you know lord lord well
look look what i did
you know they're calling him lord which
means they basically
wanted to be on his side they believed
it
and and here god is saying depart from
me you
you workers of iniquity right now now
you know god is very patient god is very
like loving
and he he's in the business of trying to
save people he
wants people to be saved but adding and
teaching confusion
to him where other people may get
steered off course
um i think it was keith that brought up
something really interesting
like a ship you can't just turn a ship
you know what i mean like you have to
actually like veer it off and it takes a
long time
and the the more you just subtly turn it
one or two degrees
you go down the road enough and it's
massive degrees apart but it didn't
start apart like that
it started in the in the vein of truth
and so that that's where i see this kind
of a thing
is it's like you know there may be huge
chunks of it that people may get a
blessing from
but there's just those degrees that are
just off-kilter just enough
that all of a sudden it starts rewriting
you know the the
the important truths that i think will
keep you found around
grounded very good point one guy
actually put together a
word chart of the words from the
movement he's in
brian's aim and not the guy who put
together the word chart
uh but the who this guy is
the the words that are commonly used in
the in his
and um let me see the numbers
at the bottom okay so the esv uses the
all these words total 264 times
the nkjv uses them all 247 times
uh the niv uses them 292. nasb uses 266
but this one uses all of them a total of
1087.
wow that's a lot more it's a complete
it's completely
different doctrine than the bible itself
yeah you know this is not even the whole
bible it's just the new testament that
he stuffed all this
in right right now imagine what happens
when it's a whole thing
i think this is this is why when you
have the old testament
and you go back and forth and you really
see them um
working together for the same kind of
concepts
it it is god designed it that way the
two witnesses right
they are both speaking of the same thing
but just from two totally different
perspectives
so that you can then go i understand
this concept
when you sort of unravel it or you take
it apart and you're only showing parts
and bits of it that's what's even more
alarming to me that
that he's going to slowly release these
other sections of it
then you really have like no real
comparison or you know
until you basically collect them all
that's an excellent point it is
nearly impossible to understand
revelation without the old testament
that's right
that's right so just wow there's so many
parts that that actually
um get its foundation in the old
testament
that when you remove that then you have
no bearing to where that truth came from
and then it could mean whatever you
wanted to to mean and you could
interject if you especially when you
change the words
yeah you change a few thousand more
words of it and then it's like ah that
makes sense
one thing i want to say is you know
despite all of this god is in control
that's right
right so putting aside the passion bible
because wow
there are many um great translations and
as michael was listing off that do have
these little differences
but where i find peace is that the
principle is the same
how do you gain salvation it's through
jesus christ
you know what do i need to do to to be
right with god the principles within the
books are
are still there and with the help of the
holy spirit we can use these
translations
to to lead someone to christ and also
have ourselves have a personal
connection with christ
right yeah it's also a call to just
really know
you know why you believe what you
believe and know how to
understand that and prove it from the
bible that's why i think that
you know bible study is such an
important part of our christian walk
because there is a lot of these
confusing you know confusion
that is coming down in on the world
right now and it's like
you know a lot of it could sound fine
but you've got to know
like where this actually comes from yeah
i often hear a lot of
common doctrinal beliefs thrown out
there and i'm like where is that
in the bible and they're like i don't
know they can't you know
i make sure that i never respond to
somebody with
well i think or i believe i'm going to
give you scripture and i'm going to give
you a couple scriptures to back that up
but often when i have these interactions
with people they'll say
well no you know i was taught this and i
believe this and i'm like but give me
the scripture for it and i have a real
hard time
finding it or or give me something
that's way out of context
wow well any other thoughts uh you guys
wanna
no that's been very eye opening thank
you for sharing that it just shows
how powerful this last end time strong
delusion will be
that's right i think more than ever now
is the time
to really pick up your bible and
like learn to read it learn to spend
time with it
learn to dive into the truth and
understand how the bible is put together
and and as a whole it is just an amazing
book i mean
we will be studying this thing for an
eternity right
and looking back on this thing and just
going this was amazing there's so much
truth here we'll never get to the bottom
of this thing
um so michael thank you for your
expertise man and
and uh look forward to having you on
future shows and
you know blessings on your on your
theological studies
and uh you know as you as you gain a
understanding of what a lot of other
people believe
that way you can kind of really see the
line of truth and how to
to to navigate and have those
communications that point people back to
christ
uh may god bless you in those studies
may bless you all too
so thank you guys for watching um if you
guys
like this show give us a thumbs up if
you want to comment on some of the
things that you maybe have said or some
of the things that you
want us to actually look into then go
ahead and leave that comment below we do
read those comments
we do look at those suggestions and if
possible
we'll obviously respond to you about
them but thank you once again for
watching thank you for your support
and we'll see you on the next episode of
led live
[Music]
foreign